- Ich musste die Büros verkaufen.
- Und wo arbeitet ihr jetzt?
- Zu Hause oder in Cafés …
Es ist schwierig, aber es geht.
Immerhin musste ich niemanden entlassen.
- Und hast du neue Aufträge?
Ich mein', wovon willst du jetzt leben?
- Ich rede gerade mit ein
paar kleineren Firmen,
die sich für unsere Arbeit interessieren.
Ähm …
Es sieht ganz gut aus, und wenn das klappt,
können wir die Schulden bald abbezahlen.
Und du? Arbeitest bald bei Yara?
Du kannst dich ja auch
noch bei mir bewerben.
- Zuerst mache ich eine Ausbildung.
Dafür muss ich eine Sprachprüfung machen.
- Wofür brauchst du denn
diese Ausbildung?
Wenn du die Sprachprüfung gemacht hast,
kannst du doch auch studieren.
- Aber ich will nicht studieren.
- Du willst also wirklich lieber
Zweiradmechatroniker werden?
Aber wovon willst du leben?
Womit willst du dein Geld verdienen?
Mit kaputten Fahrrädern?
- Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es dir geht,
aber ich habe keine Schulden.
- Ich will ja nur,
dass du jetzt keinen Fehler machst.
- Okay, worum geht es hier eigentlich?
Ich muss nicht reich werden.
Ich will, dass mir meine Arbeit gefällt.
- Sag das mal unseren Eltern.
- Wieso sollte ich?
- Wir rufen sie gemeinsam an.
Wird Zeit, dass wir uns gegenseitig
helfen, oder?
- Okay. Wenn es sein muss.